ariel helwani the MMA reporter who joins
us now Ariel thanks for joining us so
set it straight is conor mcgregor
retiring well again dan thank you so
much for having me I appreciate it um so
as of right now and you've been around
this game you no longer than than me
definitely you know how it goes in
combat sports and sports in general
these things happen and and and in
combat sports promoters and and fighters
they have their issues at times you know
all about that but as of right now this
is not a hoax it's not a troll job it's
not a joke he is in fact saying you know
I'm not a part of this anymore i I'm
walking away everyone that I've talked
to sources close to this entire
situation do believe at some point when
where why how against to they don't know
but they do believe at some point he
will fight again he's a 27 year old kid
who who is in the prime of his life who
makes a lot of money who loves making
money they believe you'll come back at
some point in fight but right now this
isn't some you know elaborate joke I
could see if if he won his last fight
and then he had a disagreement with Dana
White and said look I don't want to be
part of promoting you know the rematch
I'll let you guys do it I'm training in
Iceland or wherever he's training yeah
but but he lost and I think that's where
Dana White say no no dude I need you
here you got it that that's part of I
think this happened one other time with
a fighter with with Dana White right
where he just said all right I'll take
you right off the card yep that was
prior to UFC 137 the situation there was
that Nick Diaz was coming in Nate's
brother by the way was coming over from
Strikeforce they just purchased this
organization called strike force he was
their welterweight champion and they
finally put together this dream matchup
between Nick Diaz and Georges st. Pierre
who at the time was the UFC welterweight
champion they put on this press
conference in Vegas a couple months
before the fight to announce tickets and
all that stuff and D has no shows and in
the middle of the press conference it
was it was very much surreal Dana's
fielding calls from Diaz's coach and
manager asking like where is he's just
not there so there's a famous photo of
just you know Dana at the dais GSP
sitting down and then
seat for Nick Diaz so they ended up
pulling Nick from the the card all
together eventually they did fight a
couple years later and in a weird way it
made Nick into an even bigger star the
sort of anti hero so there is a somewhat
precedent for this but a lot of people
at the time said look it's just a press
conference who cares he's going to show
up to the fight why are you doing this
and a lot of them are saying this right
now as well but it's a little more in my
opinion than just the press conference
there's a lot going on this weekend in
Las Vegas for this fight a lot of media
a lot of video shoots there they're
investing a lot of money but but I do
think that there's more this has been
brewing and that there's more going on
than just this particular week how much
power does conor mcgregor have in the
sport I think he has a tremendous amount
of power I mean if you want to live you
know pick your poison look at his social
media you know that that one tweet alone
has over 150 thousand retweets which I'm
told is more than any other athlete in
the last two years I mean the amount of
interest that this story has generated
people reaching out to me from all over
the world from Belfast you know Asia I
mean it's just a singapore to do
interviews about this story i live in
this MMA bubble as we sort of talked
about last time and sometimes i don't
realize when things sort of creep out of
the bubble this has bursted that bubble
and it's just it's fascinating to watch
i don't think that the UFC ship is going
to sink as a result of connor you know
taking this break not showing up at USC
200 but it definitely hurts them he's
the biggest draw in the sport by far
Ronda Rousey may be the face of the UFC
meaning she'll show up on the view Kelly
and Michael etc etc but he is the
biggest draw he's their biggest
moneymaker and in fact in my opinion
he's the biggest moneymaker in the
history of the sport so they do they do
feel that pain with him not being there
I don't know if he can go rogue and you
know do his own organ it's tough to do
that because you know the USC has all
these guys under contract but he is
without a doubt in my opinion right now
the most powerful fighter in the UFC
Ariel thank you for taking time out and
we'll keep an eye on this thanks for
joining us my pleasure thank you terry
ariel helwani MMA reporter the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience